ก็สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
นะคะเรียมมาเจอกับครูหญิงครั้งแรก
ๆค่ะๆตื่นเต้นนักเรียนอาจจะเคยเห็นครู
เรียมแล้วก็เห็นครูหญิงใช่ไหมคะแต่ไม่เคย
เห็นครูหญิงกับครูเรียมอยู่ด้วยกันใจค่ะ
ผู้เรียนบอกว่าตอนนี้นะคะหัวใจนะคะหัวใจ
ของคุณเรียน
ใช่นักเรียนก็บอกว่าเอานักเรียนก็จุดตื่น
เต้นแม่เราตื่นเต้นเนี่ยไปเราจะจุด
ใช่ค่ะครูผู้หญิงแต่ว่า
โอเคแต่
วันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรคะครูเรียมวันนี้อ่า
วันจันทร์ค่ะ
วันจันทร์
วัน
วันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะคืออีก
วันจันทร์ที่ 7 ถ้าวันจันทร์ที่เจ็บเดือน
อะไรคะ
เดือน
มีนาคมเดือนนี้นาคม
พ.ศต.ตะไรคะ
ผช
แล้วขอศ.อะไรคะ
ขอ
ศ2002 2 ค่ะ
ป่าว
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้ล่ะคะผู้หญิงเป็นวันอะไร
คะอ่ะแต่เมื่อวานนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวัน
อาทิตย์
ใส่แล้วอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์ที่
เท่าไหร่คะ
วันอาทิตย์ที่ 6 ค่ะ
ว้าว
โอเคแล้ววันนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะผู้หญิง
ตอนนี้สวยไหมคะคุณเรียมตอนนี้เนี่ย 15:00
น
3:00 น
ตายค่ะ 28 นาทีค่ะ
นาที
ยี่สิบแปดนาทีนะคะ
ตายแล้วบ่ายโอเค
มีวาดวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะ
หมอเขาวาดรูปนะคะนักเรียนอะไรวันจันทร์
ครูเรียนต้องทำงานไหมคะต้องไปออฟฟิศเนาะ
มีคอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็ทำงานวันจันทร์คูณ
เรียนทำงานไหมคะวันจันทร์ครูเรียมทำงาน
ค่ะ
ทำงานโรงเรียนครูหญิงเหมือนกันค่ะวัน
จันทร์เนี่ยทำงานว่าวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
สระวันเสาร์
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
ครูเรียมเนี่ยทำงานไหมคะ
ไม่ค่ะวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์เตรียมไม่ได้ทำ
งาน
แล้วผู้หญิงล่ะคะ
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
ทำงานไหมคะ
ไม่ทำงานค่ะขยี้เยอะเล่นเพลง
วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์นะจ้ะไม่ทำงานน้องวัน
จันทร์ถึงวันศุกร์ทำนาย
เหมือนกันค่ะงาน
ผู้หญิงกับครูเรียนหน่อยนะคะโจ๊กวันเสาร์
ที่ชอบนะคะ
เด็กชอบวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์เนาะแล้ววัน
เพราะว่าเมื่อวานเนี่ยมันเป็นวันอาทิตย์
ใช่ไหมเมื่อวานเนี้ยวันอาทิตย์ที่ 6 ใช่
ไหมคะ
วันอาทิตย์ที่ 6 เนี่ยครูเรียมไม่ได้ทำ
งาน
ไม่ค่ะ
เป็นวันหยุด
ไม่ได้ทำงานไม่ได้ทำงานแล้วเมื่อวานวัน
อาทิตย์เนี่ยครูเรียมไม่ได้ทำงานจะทำอะไร
ไหมคะ
เมื่อวานนี้เตรียมออกไปออกไปนอกบ้าน
เองอ๋องั้นก็แปลว่าครูเรียมแหละอยู่บ้าน
ใช่ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้อยู่เสาร์อาทิตย์เตรียม
อยู่ที่บ้านได้แต่ว่าไม่อยู่
ไปไหนคะ
แม่อยู่อ่ะก็กูเรียนบอกว่าเมื่อวานเลยอ่ะ
ออกไปข้างนอกบ้าน
ใช่ค่ะที่ไหน
ออกไป
ร้านกาแฟ
มีหลานกะหร
ใส่ค่ะครูเรียมไปร้านกาแฟตอนกี่โมงคะ
เมื่อวานออก
ไปตอน
10:00 นค่ะ
7:00 น
7:00 นคู่เตรียมไปซื้อกาแฟหรอคะ
ก็ไปนั่ง
นั่งดู YouTube
ในร้านกาแฟก็เหอะ
ที่ร้านกาแฟคนเดียวคุณเรียมคนเดียวหรือ
ว่ามีครูเรียนแล้วก็มีเพื่อนเพื่อนๆ
เพื่อนๆหลายๆคนมีเพื่อนอีกคนนึงค่ะ
ใช่มีเรียมแล้วก็มีเพื่อน
ไปร้านกาแฟ 2 คน
ดีไหมแล้วคู่เตรียมนั่งอยู่ในร้านกาแฟ
เนี่ยหน้านานไหมคะกี่ชั่วโมงหมู
ก็เตรียมนั่งเนร้านกาแฟ
ประมาณ
[เพลง]
3 ชั่วโมงค่ะ
อยู่ 3 ชั่วโมง 3 ชั่วโมง
10:00 นจนถึง
11  12
จนถึง 1:00 น
ใช่ค่ะคือผู้หญิงชั่วโมงดื่มกาแฟกี่แก้ว
คะนั่งอยู่ 3 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมเอกกาแฟร้อน
ใช่ไหมค่ะดื่มกาแฟเนี่ยกี่แก้วค่ะดื่ม
กาแฟ
2 แก้วค่ะหวีหญิงหรือไปสองแก้วแล้วพอไป
ร้านกาแฟเสร็จแล้วคุณเรียมไปไหนไหมหรือ
ว่ากลับบ้าน
ไม่ค่ะถ้าไม่กลับบ้าน
ไปไหนคะ
ไปปั่นจักรยานค่ะ
นี้
กูเตรียมมีจักรยานหรอ
จักรยานใช่ค่ะเรียงนี้จักรยานจักรยาน
จักรยานจักรยานเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะผู้หญิงจะให้
ชื่อ
ตัวผู้หญิงขี้เกียจว่านะคะจักรยานค่ะ
อ๋อ
ปั่นจักรยานค่ะคู่หญิงคู่เตรียมไปปั่น
จักรยานไปกับเพื่อนเหรอคะหรือว่าครูเรียม
ไปปั่นจักรยานคนเดียวไปกับเคลื่อนอีกคน
นึงค่ะก็คือไปปั่นต่อคน
คุยกันปั้นจักรยานนานไหมชั่วโมงคะอ่ะ
เลิกงานประมาณบ่ายอาญาเนี่ยตั้งแต่
13:30 นค่ะไปปั่นจักรยาน
ใจค่ะนอน 1 ชั่วโมงก็ถึงประมาณบ่าย 14:30
นให้ค่ะถึง 02:30 น
แล้วปกติเนาะวันวันอาทิตย์เนี่ยนะคะวัน
อาทิตย์เนี่ยไหว้ครูเรียนเนี่ย
จักรยานทุกวันแวะไม่ใช่ทุกวันเนาะทุกวัน
อาทิตย์เนี่ยครูเรียมปั่นจักรยานไหมคะไม่
ค่ะ
แดดร้อนค่ะคุณหญิง
แดดร้อนมากไทย
พระอาทิตย์พระที่ประเทศไทยคะอันนี้พระ
อาทิตย์จะยุโรปอเมริกานะคะเล็กๆอันนี้ไม่
ร้อน
[เพลง]
เนื้อที่ใหญ่ครูหญิงเนี่ยครู Real น่ะดี
มากนะคะกันอาทิตย์ไปปั่นจักรยาน
ให้ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงอ่ะฮะวันอาทิตย์
นอนค่ะ
ขิงนอนผู้หญิงตื่นกี่โมงคะ
ทุเรียนทอกเกอร์
เห้ยวันอาทิตย์ใช่มั้ยถ้าปกตินะคะวัน
จันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธวันพฤหัสวันศุกร์
เนี่ยผู้หญิงจะตื่นประมาณ
7:30 น
7:30 นน่ะตื่นแต่ถ้าวันอาทิตย์นะวัน
อาทิตย์เนี่ยไม่ต้องทำงานใช่ไหมผู้หญิงก็
ตื่นประมาณ
10:00 น
7 ไหมคะ 10 โมง
แล้วครูยังไม่ทานข้าวเช้าหรอ
กินข้าวเช้าตอนเวลานอนอิ่มค่ะไม่ต้องแต่
เวลาตื่นมาเนี่ยมันก็หิวนะหิว
ตื่นตอนแต่ผิดโมงแล้วก็หิว
ซะแล้วก็กินข้า
งงใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงก็กินประมาณ
10 ก็นั่งสุดประมาณเที่ยงนะเหมือนตอน
เช้าไม่กินข้าวใช่ไหมคะใช่ที่เที่ยงอ่าน
ผู้เรียนเนี่ยอยู่บ้านนะอยู่บ้านใช่ไหม
ผู้หญิงน่ะไม่ได้อยู่บ้านเนาะอยู่
Condominium เอางานเย็นนะคะ Apartment
Condominium ก็วันอาทิตย์เนี่ยวัน
อาทิตย์เนี่ยกูหญิงก็จะไปสู้และก็มาเก็ต
เดี๋ยวไปซื้อหมูไปซื้อไก่ไม่ซื้อซื้อ
แครอทป๊อกเคอรี่มาทำอาหาร
เพราะว่าไม่ได้งานใจไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตคน
เดียวหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะไปคนเดียว
โง่แล้วก็ไปซื้อมาทำอาหาร
จ่ายค่ะหากผู้หญิงก็จะเดินใช่ไหมจาก
อพาร์ตเมนต์เนี่ยก็เดินเดินเดินเดินมาตรง
นี้ก็จะมีถนนนะคะถนนแล้วก็มอเตอร์ไซค์ไป
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตนะคะแล้วก็ซื้อ
แล้วก็มอเตอร์ไซค์
กลับ
Apartment น้ำมานั่งบ่ไซกะโป้ขาเราหาย
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตอยู่ไกลกับคอนโดครูหญิง
ไหมคะ
ถ้านั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์ก็ประมาณ
ไม่รู้
ไม่รู้ประมาณ 5 นาทีมั้ยไม่ที่ 5 นาที
ใกล้ว่าไม่เดินค่ะพูดเหมือนไม่ใช่หรอกจ๊ะ
ไม่ใช่ 30 นาที 30 บาทค่ะกูกูเรียม
มอเตอร์ไซค์เนี่ย 30 บาท
ไม่ดึงเงิน
อ๋อๆใช่จ่ายแต่ว่าวันอาทิตย์เนี่ยนะคะ
ปกติวันวันอาทิตย์คู่หญิงก็จะไป
ซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
น้องไม่ซื้อของ
แต่ถ้าวันเสาร์ขอถ้าเป็นวันเสาร์มาค่ะวัน
พี่น้องวันเสาร์เราสองคนก็ไม่ได้ทำงานอ่า
ช่างวันอาทิตย์เนี่ยไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ต
ใช่ไหมคะวันเสาร์เนี่ย
ไม่ไม่ไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตค่ะวันเสาร์ผู้
หญิงไปไหนคะ
โลกวันวันจันทร์วันอังคารพุธพฤหัสวัน
ศุกร์นะเราทำงาน
เรื่อยๆใช่ไหมคะวันเสาร์เนี่ยเราก็ต้อง
แบบฟาทำไมไม่ไปปั่นจักรยานนะคะเหนื่อย
เหมือนกันนะคะผู้หญิงก็จะต้องไปดูหนังแม่
ตอนนี้เนี่ยเขามีอะไรนะคะ Batman มันไปดู
แบทแมนมีเวลาสมัยก็ไปดูหนัง
แล้ววันเสาร์ผู้หญิงตื่น
10:00 นเหมือนกันไหมคะ
เหมือนกันค่ะเหมือนกันออกเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
โอ้มายทำงานเนี่ยตื่นสายตื่น 10:00 ได้งู
สบายๆไงไม่รู้คิดออกวันนี้พูดอะไรพูดอะไร
ไม่ต้องแล้วครูเรียมคะวันอาทิตย์เนี่ย
ทุเรียนไปดื่มกาแฟไปปั่นจักรยานแล้ววัน
เสาร์ล่ะวันเสาร์ครูเรียนทำอะไรไหมคะวัน
เสาร์เรียมอยู่ที่บ้านค่ะ
ก็ซักผ้าบ้าน
อยู่บ้านเฉยๆว่าซักผ้า
ๆถูบ้านล้างจาน
ใช่ค่ะกลับผ้าถูบ้าน
ล้างจาน
แล้วผู้หญิงล่ะคะวันเสาร์
วันเสาร์อ่ะ
พี่หนิงไปดูหนังอย่างเดียวหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าคุยก็ตื่น 10:00 นใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็อาบน้ำ
ใส่เสื้อในใส่เสื้อเขียนขี้ริ้วที่ทาปาก
ก็ใช้เวลาแล้วก็หมูแท็กซี่ไป SF  Cinema
สวยไปดูหนังไหมดูเสร็จก็กลับล่ะกลับ
คอนโดมิเนียม
เราก็
เหมือนครูเรียมค่ะซักผ้า
ซักผ้า
ๆ
ทุกคนนะเวลาที่วันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธ
ผลพฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์ใช่ไหมจันทร์ถึงศุกร์
เนี่ยเราต้องทำงานมีออฟฟิศวันเสาร์ใช่ไหม
คะวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์เนี่ยเราถ้าเราทำงาน
บางคนก็คืออยู่บ้านไม่ทำอะไรใช่มั้ยใช่
นอนดูทีวี
สบายๆอ่าใช่ค่ะหลายๆคนก็แตกผู้หญิงสายอะ
แต่ผู้หญิงแหละวันอาทิตย์อ่ะวันเสาร์
เนี่ยอาจจะไปเที่ยวเนาะไปเที่ยวก็อาจจะไป
ดูหนังไปช้อปปิ้งสวยไปเดินเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์
ไปเที่ยวผู้แต่วันอาทิตย์
ไปช้อปปิ้งค่ะไปซื้อไม่ใช่ว่าชอบวิ่งไป
ซุปเปอร์มาเก็ตสวยสำหรับทำอาหาร
ผู้หญิงทำอาหารกินเองที่บ้านหรอคะ
เมื่อได้ค่ะผู้หญิงเนี่ยทำอาหารกินเองแต่
ก็ยังไม่ชอบทำอาหารนะทำอาหารไม่ชอบอ่ะ
เด็กผู้หญิงแต่ไฟซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตซื้อแต่
ว่าไม่ไม่ทำ
เข้าหนังทำทำอาหารแต่ถ้าสมมติครูเรียมมา
ที่บ้านซอยแล้วค่ะผู้หญิงทำอาหารกูเรียม
กิน
ไม่เอา
ไว้ชอบแต่ถ้ากูหญิงทำอาหารแล้วก็กิน
ok ทำได้แล้ว
ผู้หญิงชอบนี้กินอะไร
ตกคุยชอบกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวค่ะอ๋อชอบแม่
มีก๋วยเตี๋ยวเยอะนะมีก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวก๋วยเตี๋ยวก๋วยเตี๋ยวก็เจอก็
เจอก็เจอก๋วยเตี๋ยวก๋วยเตี๋ยวเป็น
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวก๋วยเตี๋ยวเป็นก๋วยเตี๋ยวมากๆ
บางร้านหนูอร่อยบางร้านอ่า
ธรรมดา
น่าจะวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์ก็กินได้
ผู้หญิงไปกินคนเดียวหรอคะ
ๆค่ะผู้หญิงอยู่คนเดียวกินคนเดียวหมูโอ๋
นี่เขาว่าแบบตอนนี้ด้วยเนาะบางทีแหละเรา
ก็ไม่ได้เจอเพื่อนสวยก็พรุ่งนี้หรือคน
เดียว
ใช่เพราะว่าเราต้องอยู่ห่างๆกันเหมือนกัน
ค่ะเมื่อก่อนวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์เจอเพื่อน
มากๆ
ตอนนี้
คนเดียวสองคน
จ่ายค่ะใช่เปลี่ยนเมื่อก่อนกับตอนนี้วัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์ไม่เหมือนกันได้
คะอันนี้ก็เป็นวันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์นะคะของ
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงสวย
ๆกูเลี้ยงไปปั่นจักรยาน
ไปร้านกาแฟผู้หญิงจะไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตนะ
คะไปซื้อของเราไม่รู้นักเรียนทำอะไร
ใช่ค่ะไม่รู้
ถ้าเกิดนักเรียนถึงจะบอกผู้หญิงครูเรียน
ก็คอมเม้นมาด้านล่างนะคะ
ว่าอยู่บ้านเหมือนกันหรือเปล่า
ใช่หรือว่านักเรียนดูยูทูปครูหญิงเลี้ยง
ดีไทยค่ะดีค่ะ
ส่วนวีดีโอนี้เราสองคนรถต้องไปก่อนใช่ไหม
คะไทยค่ะเดี๋ยวไว้เจอกันใน udio หน้า
น้องวันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะไม่ก่อน
แล้วค่ะค่ะคุณหญิงสวัสดีก็
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนม